[Music]
on this wednesday night could a
recession be on the horizon
consumers and businesses need to be
prepared what rising inflation and
rising interest rates could mean for the
economy and for you re-infection risks
i've got copied four times while being
vaccinated how it's happening how to
prevent it and what won't boost your
immunity rejected we do not accept your
apology reaction to the toronto police
chief saying sorry for systemic racism
in the force and the browser getting
dragged to the recycle bin it's after 20
years of being a laughingstock why
internet explorer is being swept into
the dustbin of history
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a look at the
turmoil in the world economy the u.s
central bank has just raised its
benchmark interest rate by
three-quarters of a percentage point the
sharpest hike in almost three decades
here's why the u.s is facing a slowing
economy and soaring inflation the cost
of almost everything is going up u.s
inflation hit a 40-year high of 8.6
percent in may and it is not alone data
compiled by pew research shows inflation
has risen even faster in many other oecd
countries since the pandemic began
israel tops the list followed by greece
italy and spain the u.s and canada are
closer to the middle of the pack
inflation has been so low for so long an
entire generation doesn't remember what
can happen when it rises and what can
happen when interest rates begin to rise
too in an effort to slow down rising
prices and gaviola has our top story on
what it means for economic growth and
for you
we're strongly committed to bringing
inflation back down
and we're moving expeditiously to do so
tough measures aimed at a tough problem
inflation in the u.s at 8.6 percent
leaving central banks in the u.s and
canada to walk a fine line the 1970s
were a lesson on what not to do by not
acting quickly enough to tackle
inflation for years central bankers were
then forced to act aggressively
increasing rates to 20 percent in the
early 80s that pushed north america and
most of the world into the deepest
recession since world war ii central
banks on both sides of the border
signaling they're prepared to do a lot
to tackle inflation but there's a
concern that by targeting the rising
cost of living the u.s could go into a
recession and canada could follow bond
and stock markets suggest that's in the
cards but economists are divided on
whether or not we're headed there well
because the bounce back from the
pandemic was much stronger in the u.s
the chances of
it actually
having negative growth for two
consecutive quarters is is is higher and
that increases in my view the
possibility the probability that it
could tip into a recession i don't think
the most likely scenario is a recession
boosting interest rates taps the brakes
on economic growth by making the cost of
borrowing more expensive for households
and businesses and cooling demand but an
economic downturn which could come this
fall typically takes a toll on
employment household incomes and the
housing market we've already seen a
calming of the real estate frenzy that
took over during the pandemic with ultra
low interest rates economists say people
who took on variable rate mortgages they
may not be able to afford soon is a real
concern so were low-income households
that were hit hard by covid restrictions
recessions aren't something to fear it
does create a lot of volatility but at
the end of the day i think that the most
likely scenario is that we're going to
see a slowing in the economy and it's
something that that consumers and
businesses need to be prepared for the
hope is that some sort of slowdown may
be the shock the canadian economy needs
and is ready to withstand
ann gaviola global news toronto
there are lots of factors beyond
canada's borders driving up inflation
russia's war in ukraine and the impact
on gas prices supply chain problems and
shortages of labor those last two are a
lingering effect of the pandemic public
health restrictions have eased but
people are still getting covet and
increasingly they're getting it more
than once vaccines certainly reduce the
risk of serious illness and death but as
jamie morocco reports re-infection is
something we're going to have to get
used to
despite best efforts of many of us
canadians are coming down with covid
time and time again i've been vaccinated
i've got copied four times while being
vaccinated even our fully vaccinated
prime minister isn't immune attending
question period virtually while he gets
over his second case in six months we're
looking at a probable future where if
we're engaging in the kinds of social
behaviors we've become used to in the
last few years
pre-pandemic
we're each looking at two three four
infections per year covet reinfection
depends on a couple of things experts
say new mutations being won federal data
is limited but the latest information
shows while omicron's ba-2 is dominant
in canada sub-variants ba-4 and 5 are
making gains in the u.s those
sub-variants already account for 21
percent of infections and european
health officials say they are spreading
more rapidly than others if you were
infected with omicron or any of the
sub-variants it doesn't mean that you're
good and protected for the next few
weeks or months or whatever it is that
people think that brings us to infection
immunity there's a growing list of
evidence to suggest omicron specifically
does very little to protect you from
catching the virus again and while covet
is here to stay experts are still
adamant vaccinating the youngest
canadians and boosting the most
vulnerable will help as will strain
specific shots and even new nasal
vaccines if you are still infected it
can help you clear that infection more
quickly and that's the important part
because if you clear the infection
you're less likely to pass it on to
somebody else which is important and it
also gives the virus less chance to
replicate in you diminishing kovid's
ability to evolve meaning less chance at
repeat infection the effects of which we
still know very little about jamie
morocco global news toronto
the u.s fda has taken a big step towards
approving code 19 vaccines for young
children an expert panel is endorsing
the use of moderna and pfizer vaccines
as safe and effective for kids age six
months to five years that sets the stage
for the fda to green light the shots and
they could begin being administered as
early as next week canada hasn't taken
that step but our national advisory
committee on immunization tends to
follow the us fda
toronto police admitted today what
activists in that city have said for a
long time that people of color are
disproportionately targeted by the
police and systemic discrimination is
real here's what the police chief said
we have not done enough to ensure that
every person in our city receives fair
and unbiased policing
and for this
as chief of police and on behalf of the
service
i am sorry
and i apologize unreservedly
the force released race-based data on
thousands of use of force incidents and
strip searches and the picture the data
paints is clear the question is what
beyond that apology do police intend to
do about it eric sorenson reports
that was a plane clothes toronto police
officer about two years ago taking down
a suspect forcefully for many black
people it has always seemed that the
police treat them differently i've been
searched
i have been following around jack
goldson has felt discriminated against
by the police he thinks because he's
black ever since i came to canada in the
80s the same thing nothing changed today
toronto police admitted systemic racism
persists in the force their own data
from 2020 showing disparities in police
encounters with indigenous people middle
eastern and other minorities but the
clearest evidence involved black people
police have found that black people are
more than two times more likely to have
interactions with police are more likely
to have firearms pointed at them and to
have force used against them i apologize
unreservedly an apology and a promise
that toronto police will do better to
address discrepancies in use of force in
strip searches and will improve reviews
of body-worn cameras our goal is to
focus our efforts on the systemic bias
attributable to our actions one
frustrated activist confronted the
police chief in the middle of the news
conference the black community never
asked for an apology what we have asked
for you to do is to stop to stop
brutalizing us outside another called
for drastic measures defunding this
police force and reallocating their
resources so they can't hurt us like
this anymore in fact police budgets are
likely to grow as the population grows
others say long-held prejudices and
attitudes must be recognized and
addressed change your policing policies
change your training practices the
stereotypes we have picked up over the
years
a lot of unlearning needs to happen jack
goldson is skeptical that he will ever
see real change black people does not
have a chance with the police that's the
challenge confronting toronto police
with racialized communities building
trust after their own findings confirmed
just how serious the problem is with
systemic racism in the force eric
sorensen global news toronto
a recently retired lieutenant general in
the canadian military has been charged
with two counts of sexual assault trevor
cadu was under investigation by military
police when senior military leadership
approved his request to retire the
charges relate to incidents alleged to
have happened at the royal military
college in kingston ontario our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson has more
information mercedes
donna military police have charged
trevor cadu with two counts of sexual
assault the charges stem from an alleged
rape dating back to kaju's time as a
cadet at the royal military college in
1994. royal military college has been at
the center of a number of allegations
and louise arbour raised serious
concerns about the college and its
culture around sexual misconduct in her
report kaiju is currently in ukraine
where he's been serving as a senior
advisor to the ukrainian military after
suddenly retiring from the canadian
armed forces in april he was scheduled
to take command of the canadian army
last fall but that reception was quietly
shut down just days before it was set to
take place after a sexual assault
investigation was opened up there are
questions about when senior ranks of the
military learned about the concerns
around kadja katja had been promoted to
three leaf general for the job as army
commander and while he never actually
worked as a lieutenant general he did
retire as one in a statement kaju said
he is returning from ukraine and will
cooperate with the judicial process in
canada he has previously called the
allegations against him false military
police kept control of the investigation
in this case since their work was almost
complete but the case will be tried in
civilian court
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thank you
new aid for ukraine coming up the much
needed weaponry the u.s and canada are
promising to send
the united states has pledged to send
one billion dollars in weapons and
humanitarian aid to ukraine answering a
call from ukraine's president who says
without more heavy weaponry russia will
keep making gains the shipment will
include anti-ship rocket systems
artillery rockets howitzers and a heavy
supply of ammunition
when you're in the fight you can never
get a get enough and you can never get
it quick enough so but having said all
that
you know we're going to work hard to
make sure we're doing everything
humanly possible we're going to continue
to move heaven and earth to get them the
capability that they need
canada was at that nato meeting in
brussels today and pledged nine million
dollars of military aid in the form of
replacement barrels for howitzers and
more than twenty thousand rounds of
ammunition as crystal commansing reports
ukrainian forces in the east of the
country desperately need everything they
can get
and they are defending their homeland
with resolve grit and ingenuity with the
united states at the helm 50 supportive
countries called the contact group came
together for the third time coordinating
weapons donations training and
replacement parts to arm ukraine they're
fighting for the very life of their
country
so your ability to endure suffering your
ability to endure casualties is directly
proportional to the object to be
attained
russia released images wednesday of
cruise missiles being fired at ukraine
after the country refused to surrender
sever donesk about 80 percent of that
city has been seized by russian forces
[Music]
but the industrial zone including the
chemical plant where civilians and
soldiers are sheltering remains under
ukrainian control
russia however is determined to take the
eastern region of the country known as
the donbass
the person who wants to capture
everything will never stop after
capturing just a part of what he wants
in addressing the czech parliament
vladimir zelensky pleaded for a seventh
round of sanctions against russia as his
country awaits delivery of more heavy
and long-range weapons
by the end of the month shipments from
canada and other allied nations will
include more howitzer m triple sevens
plus high mobility artillery rocket
systems which users are being certified
on when you're in the fight you can
never get a get enough and you can never
get it quick enough in the meantime
ukrainians kiss and hug goodbye
hoping vulnerable loved ones in the east
can be taken to safety crystal gamansen
global news
london
u.s prosecutors have filed federal hate
crime charges against the accused gunman
in last month's mass shooting at a
buffalo new york supermarket the u.s
attorney general went to buffalo today
to visit the memorial 10 people were
killed while shopping at the store that
serves a largely black neighborhood
investigators believe the 18 year old
suspect was motivated by the great
replacement theory a racist conspiracy
theory that non-white individuals are
being brought into the u.s and other
western countries to replace white
voters and achieve a political agenda
the accused has been charged with 10
counts of hate crimes resulting in death
along with a number of firearms offenses
and could face the death penalty
dirty money ahead the long awaited
report into money laundering in bc
sweeping changes are needed to tackle
money laundering in bc which a public
inquiry has concluded has allowed
billions of dollars of dirty money to be
laundered and it says the crimes have
been poorly understood and largely
ignored by law enforcement the final
report of the cullen inquiry recommends
changes to everything from law
enforcement to real estate to banking
regulations richard zusman has been
unpacking the 1800 page report richard
lots of recommendations including the bc
appoint a commissioner to oversee
tackling the problem because i guess
what's in place now clearly doesn't work
it sure doesn't don and a lot of
criticism around federal regulations as
well let me read you one of the first
lines the federal anti-money laundering
regime is not effective
austin cullen the commissioner of this
inquiry finding fintrac's reporting
regime is essentially wasteful and the
rcmp had a lack of attention on all of
this so it's led to some really
substantial findings let me show you
some of those hundreds of millions of
dollars laundered through bc casinos and
the housing market the bc real estate
sector is still highly vulnerable to
money laundering effective regulation of
the mortgage lending industry is
essential and monolid laundering is not
the cause of housing unaffordability in
this province there are also some
crucial findings the province should
establish an anti-money laundering
commissioner create new provincial money
laundering intelligence and
investigative units and increase
regulation for mortgage brokers in the
real estate industry
i think there was a
lack of will
that um that underlay uh bclc's approach
to the the question
and um it was
um difficult uh to for
uh
bclc to deal with
some of the issues they had
richard the commissioner said much of
this takes place in the shadows but some
of it is out in the open how much blame
did the commissioner put on politicians
they found that politicians here in
british columbia including former
premier christie clark knew about
suspicious activity and didn't do enough
but fell short of calling these
politicians corrupt and the line of the
day donna comes from attorney general
david eby saying that it's not enough
for him just to put a sash around
someone's neck that says not corrupt he
holds himself and other politicians to a
much higher standard
all right lots to watch for richard
zussman in victoria tonight thanks
people in bc southern interior are under
a flood emergency tonight
heavy rain in kelowna has caused at
least three creeks to burst their banks
flooding nearby properties more rain is
in the forecast over the next 24 hours
and emergency crews are filling sandbags
to protect as many homes as possible and
have been inspecting bridges for debris
and blockages
in calgary the threat of flooding from
days of constant rain has now been
downgraded but the city is not out of
the woods water levels have peaked in
the elbow and bow river both remain
under a high streamflow advisory and
conditions can change quickly at this
time of year as temperatures rise
potentially triggering a rapid spring
melt in the mountains
whoa
that's the moment a car was hit by a
rockslide in yellowstone national park
heavy rain and flooding there caused
dramatic damage over the weekend the new
video emerged today as officials say the
park's landscape has been dramatically
changed more than ten thousand visitors
were forced to flee hundreds of homes
were damaged
next surfs over the internet's most
notorious inconvenience closes its
windows for good
it's not getting any eulogies or tearful
farewells but an influential giant of
our times has left us today the internet
explorer web browser is officially being
retired by microsoft as dan spector
tells us while some are wishing at good
riddance others are actually feeling a
wave of nostalgia
back in a time when your internet
browsing session could be ruined by
someone picking up the phone
the gateway to a world wide web full of
awkward myspace accounts and personal
websites under construction was
microsoft internet explorer hattie
partovi is one of the fathers of the
storied software first released in 1995.
at the time when
i was leading the project i remember
thinking this is something that
could last forever
but alas it did not the official end of
its life june 15 2022 microsoft saying
in a blog post it will no longer support
ie
after 20 years of being a laughingstock
it's now just sort of
being put out of its misery this
department filed an anti-trust suit
against microsoft describing the
bundling of internet explorer in windows
95 as an illegal tie-in the next
sentence reads the latest uh confirmed
killer app is the web browser recall
writing that sir no
this became this collision about
monopoly power and the influence of
these larger tech giants on the
development of our communications
internet explorer's dominance gradually
faded until google's chrome browser
became king
chrome on my desktop and safari on my
phone
a day to mourn the internet of the past
and as this gravestone posted to a
korean message board says a moment to
honor a browser whose main use ended up
being to download other browsers dan
specter global news montreal
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the old time country fair
held in neverville manitoba last weekend
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye
[Music]
you